so our opponent for today is uh
primarily we're going to focus on what
I'll refer to as non-parametric few shot
learning methods this is a pretty cool
class of methods that actually seems to
work really really well for a few shot
classification problems
and it will also be part of homework too
in addition to some of the topics that
we had covered on Monday
we'll also look at a case study in
education where we actually deployed
these systems for a real live
application which is pretty exciting
um and then once we kind of talk about
these this class of methods we'll also
talk a little bit um start to kind of
wrap up this kind of module on on metal
learning algorithms by talking about a
comparison of the three different
classes of approaches that we've talked
about
um and also give a few different example
applications
um so really the goals by the end of the
lecture are to get an understanding for
what this third class of metal learning
methods is and understand how to
implement these non-parametric few shop
meta learning methods
um and then also start to understand the
trade-offs between different metal
learning algorithms and some of the
applications of these algorithms
cool um so to briefly recap
um the last two lectures we've talked
about Black Box meta learning and
optimization based meta learning and in
Black Box meta learning we parametrize
the learning process with something like
a big black box for current neural
network by passing in a training data
set into that neural network having it
output a set of parameters and having a
new example be passed into that and kind
of trading this whole system end to end
with respect to the ability to
generalize to new data points
um this is what you've been implementing
in homework one it's a very expressive
approach in that it can represent lots
of different learning procedures uh but
it can also be somewhat challenging to
optimize and somewhat sensitive to hyper
parameters
then on the lecture on Monday we talked
about optimization-based Metal learning
algorithms that embed the structure of
gradient descent into the inner loop
learning process
and we saw that these algorithms are
because they're embedding the structure
of optimization inside this learning
process you get that nice structure and
so ad initialization you're already
going to be getting something that can
do at least a little bit of learning
from the examples that you give it
um but it does require a second order
optimization and this can be
computationally more heavy weight
especially in comparison to some of the
approaches that we'll be talking about
today
cool
um so really what we'd like to be able
to do today is we'd like to be able to
take a learning procedure
um and embed that inside the inner loop
process of these metal learning
algorithms without requiring a second
order optimization
and the way that we're going to do that
is instead of trying to embed gradient
descent into
these algorithms we're going to look at
algorithms like nearest Neighbors
and in particular you might think okay
well nearest neighbors is not a very
powerful algorithm so why why might we
actually do anything like nearest
Neighbors
um but I think like nearest neighbors
these non-parametric machine learning
methods actually work uh pretty well if
you are in a low data regime
if you have a small amount of data then
these algorithms are computationally
efficient because you don't have that
many comparisons to be making and
they're also very simple
um and at metatest time when we're
trying to do something like few shot
learning we're actually in a low data
regime and so things like nearest
neighbors may actually make a lot of
sense
um however during meta training time we
actually potentially have a large number
of tasks and we want to be able to learn
um good representations from the data
that we have and so we still want to be
parametric during meta trading time
and so really the kind of the the idea
behind the class of methods that we'll
talk about today is trying to use kind
of parametric metal Learners that
produce effective non-parametric
learners
um so it might be a little bit
mysterious uh what that exactly means so
let's get into it a little bit so
um say we want to do kind of the
canonical few shot image classification
problem that we've been looking at
before
if we want to do something like nearest
neighbors with this example what we
would do is we would take our test data
point and we would compare it to each of
our training examples
and once we figured out what which of
the training examples that was most
similar to then we can output the label
of that training example
um this is pretty simple uh
we're just going to be comparing our
test image with each of the images in
the training data set for our given task
now the key question is uh when we make
these comparisons
in what space do we compare or what
distance metric are we going to be using
to compare these images
um now one thing you could imagine doing
is doing L2 distance in pixel space so
just doing uh kind of euclidean distance
in the original space of the images
um and so if you do something like that
um say you were to compare this image on
the right with the two images on the
left
um just with this LT distance
I'm curious what you think would be uh
kind of the closer of the two images how
many people think that the left image
would be closer in terms of L2 distance
and how many people think the Right
image
okay so maybe people like maybe people
are trying to but in general there
wasn't any any sort of consensus but it
turns out that this left image is
actually in L2 space what's going to be
closer uh to this image on the right and
at least perceptually in terms of what
when we see these images at least the
image on the right is something that we
would probably want to be closer in
um in terms of our distance metric
so things like L2 distance are actually
really terrible for comparing in the
original space of things like images
so we don't want to use LT distance
does anyone have ideas for what distance
metrics we might consider using instead
of LT distance
that's very specific so you can use
you could use the settings from kind of
a trained neural network perhaps the the
fifth layer of the vdg network
um
[Music]
yeah so maybe you can learn the metric
with the training data
any other thoughts
yeah extra key points
so you could try to extract some key
points in the image and compare those uh
the key points across the images
yeah
so if you know
[Music]
it's just huge
problems
yeah so you could do something like
cosine similarity in a certain feature
space
yeah this is a suggestion but I just
feel like I'm missing something if we're
talking about excuse and distance metric
this is not a parameter like what senses
this is non-parametric effect
yeah
um so the question was
um if we're choosing the distance metric
isn't that a parameter of the method and
so in what sense is this a
non-parametric method
um and so yeah that's exactly right the
kind of the choice of distance function
is going to be parametric and in this
case we're actually going to be learning
um a distance metric which is what was
suggested that's kind of the parametric
part of it but once you have that
distance metric
the rest is non-parametric so you're
going to be kind of comparing
um in that space so once you embed into
some embedding space everything after
that is is non-parametric and so it is
going to be something that's a little
bit more hybrid The Meta learning
process will be parametric and have some
parameters that you're optimizing
um and then once you optimize those
parameters at test time there isn't
going to be
um
any kind of notion of task parameters
and we'll see that a little bit when we
get into some of the math
cool so um yeah the key idea behind this
class of methods is maybe we can learn
how to compare examples using the meta
training data
so there's three specific methods that
we'll go into and we'll start with the
simplest one
which is referred to as a Siamese
Network so a Siamese network is a pretty
simple neural network architecture where
you have two inputs and you pass those
two inputs into the same exact uh the
same exact neural network
um
and it's called the Siamese Network
because these kind of two neural
networks have the same exact parameters
so the parameters are shared across the
two
um and what we'll do is we'll pass in
two images into this Siamese Network
um and then once we have the output
we'll then compare these the resulting
representation
and we'll train the Siamese neural
network to Output whether or not the two
images we're passing in have the same
class or not
and so in this example these two images
have a different class one is of a lion
one is of cups or bowls and so the label
will be zero because these are a
different class
um likewise we could pass it these two
images which are both images of bowls
and we would train it to Output one
uh and so on and so forth so whenever we
give it two images that are different
classes we train to Output zero whenever
they're both the same class we train it
to Output one
um so the training process is a very
simple binary classification problem and
you can do this with all of the kind of
available meta training data that you
have
you have cool and then once you have the
Siamese neural network
what you can do is use this as
essentially your similarity metric or
your distance metric so you can compare
each of the you can compare your test
image to each of the examples in your
training data set and ask this network
which of the images is the closest
and so in particular if we kind of go
back to the example you have before you
would pass in all pairs of of training
example comma test data point and ask it
which has the highest probability of
being the same class and then output the
corresponding label
any questions on how that works
cool so training will be binary
classification and test time you're
running these pairwise comparisons and
so if you have n times K examples in
your training data set you're going to
be actually doing n times K forward
passes of this neural network and
finding and then finding the probability
that's the highest and then outputting
the corresponding label
um so Mediterranean is binary
classification and then meta test time
will actually be a form of endway
classification
yeah
there are more than one short learning
then I don't think
so you're asking this can't work for one
shot learning
why can't it work for one dollar so if
you only have one example of each Clause
then like if you compare you could just
die hard
so similar to what we saw in the
previous two lectures you
um you need to have at least one example
per class in your training data in your
meta training data set
um and so in your meditating data set
you need to make sure that you're not
um that for example you sample two
images per character or two images per
class uh and that ensures that you're
actually going to train it to generalize
versus
um for example if you pass in the same
exact image into the network it would
just learn to memorize and learned how
to predict whether or not they're
exactly the same image or whether
they're slightly different images
cool so
now one thing that's like not super
appealing about this kind of approach is
that we actually have this mismatch
between what's happening at mediterrane
time and what's happening at metatest
time
um and so in particular if you were
actually to kind of write out what
happens at metatest time you're going to
get something where basically you're
taking we'll call this neural network F
or F Theta
um you're going to be comparing
The Test example with
um one of with each of your training
examples so you'll be looking at this
for each of the XK in your training data
set
and you can essentially view what's
happening at metatest time as uh
well
asking this neural network whether or
not
um
kind of the probability that these match
is greater than say 0.5
and if it is greater than 0.5 outputting
the label
corresponding to that training example
so one way that you could sort of write
what's going to be happening at meta
test time would be something like this
where
uh
you're summing over all of the examples
in your training data set
comparing the test input to each of
those training samples and for the one
that has the highest probability then
outputting the corresponding label
this isn't exactly correct because the
network might actually output multiple
like more than greater than 0.5 for more
than one of the examples but this is
kind of approximately what it is doing
and this will correspond to Y hat
uh y hat k your prediction for sorry
your prediction for uh
The Test example so y-hat test
so now from this standpoint
um
if you view this as
the what's happening at meta test time
what you can imagine doing instead of
doing binary classification during train
time is formulating an equation like
this
and simply just back propagating into
Theta
and if we did something like that then
we could actually match what happens at
Mediterranean time and metatest time
now we can't do exactly that because
this this operator right here that's
basically is kind of an indicator
variable for whether or not the
probability is above 0.5 it's going to
be hard to differentiate through
something like that because it's a hard
operation
and so what you can do instead is do
something softer where
um you
simply
uh
kind of multiply this probability by YK
and sum over
your
examples
in your training data set for a given
task
and if we do something like this this
here we can actually back propagate
through this loss so this is going to be
equal to
y-hat test
and you can actually optimize the
parameters of this kind of of this
network right here with respect to how
accurate you are on test examples
and so in particular
um
the way this algorithm would look like
is it's very similar to the existing
meta training algorithms that we have
done before where first you
sample a task
so this might if we're doing three-way
classification this might correspond to
say three characters second we sample
to images per character
and then
we for the training data set this
basically corresponds to it gives us our
training data set and our test set for
that task
we plug in our training data set into
this equation here
to then get a kind of an estimate for uh
as well as kind of our test example from
the test set to get an estimate for the
label
and then when we actually go to update
Theta we're going to be looking at
um
kind of comparing the I guess I should
write this more as cross-entropy laws so
um we'll be looking at
what's the best way to something like uh
white hat test log
um white tests I
should have written this down before but
something uh I think the cross entropy
loss is actually the opposite of this
is this correct for cross-up tree loss
foreign
something like this and so then you'll
be uh
minimizing uh
the kind of parameters of our compare
basically our comparator function with
respect to how accurate your predictions
are
so more specifically what this will look
like is
um this corresponds to something called
matching Networks and what we're going
to do is we're going to encode our
training examples into
some embedding space
and then for each of those embeddings we
will compute this function that's
you could think of this as potentially
taking the dot product between your
embedding for x-test and your betting
for XK
and so in this diagram you can think of
each of these black dots as this
function right here
and then
each of these colored squares
corresponds to the to the label for that
training example
we take the dot product between
um between the the black dots and the
red or the colored squares
sum over each of the examples to
ultimately get the um
the prediction for
our best example
yeah
um how well do uh these methods work uh
unseen classes
so how will these methods work on unseen
examples at inference time so
um in general as as long as you trade it
on enough
kind of the kinds of metatrading
scenarios that we've had before where
you have enough kind of characters that
you're training it on
um it will actually generalize well to
New Image classes at test time if you
only traded on a few classes then then
it will struggle to generalize
yeah
parametric methods to constrained to
classification tasks only because you
cannot learn anything else
yeah so um that's a great a great
observation so these methods are
restricted to classification tasks uh
things like nearest Neighbors
are specific to classification
and it's not uh it's not trivial to try
to extend these kinds of ideas to
regression problems
yeah
foreign
yeah that's a great question so
um one thing you might know
actually they use a different encoder
for the test example than for the
training examples
um that's mostly just a choice of their
architecture uh you could choose to all
to put it through the same exact
embedding space and actually in the
method that we'll look at next they do
actually choose to put it in the same
exact embedding space one other note
that I'll make about this architecture
is that they
um when they embed the training examples
they actually use uh this is somewhat
old paper so they use a bidirectional
LCM if they were designing this more
recently they'd probably use a
bi-directional Transformer model
and
um that means that when it actually
computes this it could actually take
into account not just one example but
it's also kind of implicitly taking into
account the other examples in your task
training set
um but basically at a high level you can
think of this method as embedding things
doing nearest Neighbors in that
embedding space and then back
propagating all the way into the
parameters of your embedding function
of course we need to do that sort of
nearest neighbors function in a soft way
so that we could differentiate through
it and that's why we get a function that
looks like this where we are rather than
taking kind of this hard
um this hard Max we're going to be
taking more of something like a soft Max
um so the whole thing is trained end to
end and this was really the first
um one thing that's nice about this
paper is it actually really emphasizes
how you should really try to match
what's happening at mediter training
time and meta test time and they they're
able to get substantially better
performance than something like Siamese
that worked
cool um so if we walk through the
algorithm
um
we also did this somewhat on the board
but kind of more formally
um it's very similar to the algorithms
that we've seen for like the black box
approach and the optimization based
approach
um and what's different is just these um
primarily just the third step although
also the fourth step so
um in the third step instead of actually
explicitly Computing parameters for the
task we're actually going to be kind of
skipping that step and directly making
predictions for the test examples
um you can view this as kind of
integrating out the parameters that the
task parameters and hence why we're
referring these as non-parametric fee
shot learning methods
um and then of course because we are
um because we're just Computing The Test
example the test predictions directly
instead of using a loss function in the
form of step four we're going to be
updating the param The Meta parameters
simply using a loss function that
compares the predictions and the uh the
labels supposed to generalize the case
yeah that's a great question uh and that
was actually the next question on my
slide so
um
in particular uh the kind of question is
what happens if you have more than one
um
more than one example per class
so
I guess I was actually thinking about
posing this to you guys so maybe does
anyone want to answer that question
yeah so one thing you can do is you
compare the average embedding you're
sort of foreshadowing what happens
um
yeah so you could do some sort of voting
scheme and practice that's actually what
matching networks tends to do so
basically you're going to be
um this equation is still valid for
scenarios where you have more than one
example per class and essentially each
of these is going to vote on what the
label is and if you accumulate enough
votes then you will
um the kind of the thing with the the
highest kind of accumulation of those
scores
um will then kind of win the vote and
get the label get to be able to make the
prediction for the label
um now
uh there's a downside to this voting
approach which is that all the votes are
kind of cast somewhat independently of
one another
uh and this means that you might have
scenarios where
um
where the kind of test example is maybe
maybe there's like one um
one example with the incorrect label
that actually has a very high vote but
everything else has a very low vote for
that example
um and you might get examples
essentially where the
um
where
where the kind of that overpowers the
other kind of the actual correct label
and doesn't give you exactly what you
want
um as kind of one
maybe rough example for what this might
look like
um you could sort of think of this as
mimicking something a lot like nearest
neighbors and there's a failure mode for
nearest neighbors where
um if for example you have data that
maybe looks something like this where
you have just a two-way classification
problem you're trying to classify
between kind of positive and negative
examples
uh if you end up getting an example uh
that say like right here for example
um
this something like nearest neighbors
will give you a negative prediction even
though there's a lot of positives in
this General vicinity
and if instead of doing nearest
neighbors you kind of aggregate
information across the the examples into
kind of what we'll refer to as a
prototype for each class then you can
kind of start to mitigate that issue so
if you form if you if this is your
embedding space and you average the
embedding per class you'll get kind of
one prototype that is maybe kind of
somewhere right here for the positive
class and you'll get one prototype that
somewhere maybe around here for the
negative class
and then if you compare your example to
these prototypes you'll then see that
the
the kind of distance to the positive
prototype is less than the distance to
the negative prototype and then you'll
get something that's closer to the right
answer
um and so that's kind of the idea behind
the last approach that we'll talk about
which is that instead of trying to
perform these comparisons independently
we'll try to aggregate class information
to create a prototypical embedding for
each class and then compare the test
example to those prototypical examples
so we'll just do nearest neighbors so
the prototypes instead of nearest
neighbors to the individual training
examples
um cool so what that looks like is
basically exactly what's in this picture
um if you are actually to write it out
in math
um you'll get some
uh you'll compute your prototype we'll
refer to this as a c n to match the
picture
this will be
basically just an average over an
embedding of the examples for that class
and so if we take example
um
I'll use XK here we will only want to
average over the embeddings that
correspond to class n and so we're only
going to do the summation over the
examples where YK is equal to n and this
is a summation
over all of the examples in your
training data set
um so this will just this is basically
just going from these blue pluses to the
purple plus and the blue negatives for
uh to the to the purple negative this is
a very simple average
and then once we have these prototypes
we can compute the distance between
the Prototype and the test example
rather than looking at the distance
between the individual examples
um and in practice what this algorithm
will do is once you compute these
distances then you'll just negate the
distances you get a similarity score and
then take a soft Max
to ultimately get the probability that y
hat for the test example is equal to
class n
so written out on the slides we're
averaging over we embed all of our
examples using the function f
average those embeddings and so unlike
the previous slide we're actually just
going to be using the same exact
embedding function for our training
examples and our test example
um and then this is writing out the full
softmax equation where we take the
distance we compute the distance between
the example and the Prototype um and
they then kind of exponentiate and
normalize in order to compute a
probability
yeah so
um in the original paper they used
euclidean distance or cosine distance as
the distance function in practice you
could actually also learn a distance
function somewhat similar to what
matching networks does here as well
and so instead of using you could this
could be basically a learned network if
it is learned that it was going to have
the
um its parameters will be kind of a part
of you'll maybe have some additional
parameters and when you run the meta
training process you're going to
optimize over kind of it would both be
the parameters of f as well as the
parameters of this distance function
right here
um why there's a minus D here and what
oh that's a typo on this point it's
definitely yeah that's a great catch um
so on the slide that should be a minus D
in the denominator
yeah
yeah so there's a paper that I'll
mention
a few slides from now called relation
networks
um and they basically meta learn the
distance function as well
um I think that on kind of The Benchmark
problems they weren't seeing significant
benefits from using a distance function
over just using something like cosine
similarity or
um or euclidean distance and one reason
to potentially expect to not see too
many benefits is that F itself has a lot
of expressive power to embed into
whatever space you might want and that's
going to impose different distance
metrics uh and so you may not actually
need something on top of actually just
embedding into this other space but I
could also it's possible that there are
some applications where it's difficult
to impose a certain metric space and
where
um we're kind of learning something to
Output a probability is is helpful
cool um actually no so it's actually on
the Redneck Side so this is the relation
that we're paper
um they also do this sort of embedding
and then you um you compare to them but
then they lastly do this sort of
um have this kind of relation score that
corresponds to this uh this learned
distance function
now there are a couple of other things
that you could do as well so
um there might be some examples where
some of your positive and negative
examples are not easy to Cluster nicely
so for example if you're trying to
classify between cats and dogs you may
have some breeds of cats that look a lot
like dogs
and if you have something like that then
maybe you actually have kind of a
cluster over here of negatives
and if your algorithm is having a lot of
trouble actually getting like finding a
metric space where everything is
clustered together nicely
um you could also use something where
you actually have a mixture of
prototypes
um and that's what uh this paper did
here is instead of actually just having
one prototype for class they actually
had multiple prototypes per class
in a lot of examples this isn't kind of
critical for getting good performance
but it's something that's uh worth
mentioning
um and the last thing they'll mention is
that uh instead of
um doing something as simple as nearest
neighbors there are also approaches that
do something more complicated where you
do some you kind of formulate this graph
and do message passing on that graph in
order to ultimately kind of figure out
the relationship between different
examples
cool
um yeah so that's that's kind of the
gist of it for these non-parametric
methods um I guess to summarize uh
unlike the previous examples unlike
Black Box meta learning and optimization
based by learning we're not actually
ever going to be getting an estimate for
the task parameters instead we're going
to be typically Computing some embedding
space and then doing nearest Neighbors
in that embedding space
down does it converge quickly
yeah so one of the things that's really
nice about this class of methods is that
uh this
this process is entirely feed forward so
you you kind of compete your embeddings
in a feed forward Manner and then you
compete your prototypes and then you do
this this kind of distance function
um
so it ends up being like you don't have
to do any sort of gradient descent
process
um it ends up being pretty lightweight
and pretty fast to train uh and so
you'll see in homework in homework too
that this class of methods can actually
be quite nice for for classification
problems
I
just what is message passing um
I that's going into that in depth is
beyond the scope of what I'll cover in
lecture
um message passing is a
um but I guess very briefly
um you can think of message passing as
if you have a graph
um of kind of in this case a graph of
different examples and you have some
kind of
uh some notion of like how these
examples are related to each other like
some of the examples maybe have a very
strong relationship some of the examples
have a weaker relationship uh message
passing algorithms basically try to
um pass messages along the edges of that
graph uh and you iteratively pass
messages in order to
ultimately try to converge to
um
kind of some notion about the the kind
of true relation between these examples
but I encourage you to kind of you can
read this paper for more detail there's
also if you take like Stefano's course
on deep generative models he also I'm
pretty sure covers undirected graphical
models and things like message passing
there
green
[Music]
require
a great descent
the test time
all of them require a form of gradient
descent in order to optimize your your
objective to optimize your embedding
experience
cool
um so
I like to kind of run through a case
study of actually using this algorithm
in practice
um I put one example of a previous
year's case study on the slides that was
actually in a pretty cool Healthcare
setting where they're looking at image
classification of trying to classify
different skin conditions and skin
diseases
um but the case study that I want to
cover this year is an example in
education that I'm pretty excited about
I'm a little bit biased because I was
involved in the effort but uh I think
education is a really cool application
area
um and I should also mention kind of at
the start of this project we really had
no idea how hard the problem would like
how hard or easy the problem would be
and so
um yeah it was kind of rewarding to see
see how it went
so
um the problem that we were looking at
is uh
the feedback problem and as one instance
of this problem
uh there was a course offered by some
folks at Stanford called code in place
similar to shelter in place while you're
Sheltering in place you could code in
place
and it was a free course free intro to
computer science course
um and in the second iteration of the
course it had more than 12 000 students
from more than 150 different countries
across the world
um and in the course they gave that kind
of a diagnostic exam to help students
understand where they were at with the
material and they wanted to be able to
give feedback on the diagnostic and what
the diagnostic was the students
submitted open-ended python code
Snippets that was trying to solve
different problems and they estimated
that if you were to try to give feedback
on all of the students code it would
take a very long time in particular take
you more than eight months to try to do
that and so for this reason actually in
the first iteration of the course they
didn't give any feedback to students on
this diagnostic they just took it and
then they got to see what the solutions
were we tried to see if we could give
feedback to the students
um now there's a way to formulate this
as a classification problem and in
particular on in many of the courses
that you've probably taken at Stanford
when you submit assignment or an exam
you get feedback through a rubric which
tells you what kinds of misconceptions
you made on a given question
and we can formulate rubric grading as a
classification problem where the input
the X example is the open-ended python
code
and the label is
um corresponds to basically filling out
the rubric
and so each rubric will be a multi-label
classification problem where you need to
be able to predict whether or not the
student has that particular
misconception
now you might think well okay if this is
a classification problem it must be
pretty easy to solve because like
classification is is pretty
straightforward with machine learning
um
but the challenge with it is that first
we don't have that much annotation data
we don't have tons of data on the
internet that tells us like feedback on
student programs there's also these long
tail distributions where students will
solve problems in many many different
ways
uh and then lastly and perhaps most
importantly every time you give an
assignment or an exam usually it's
somewhat different from the previous
time that exam or assignment was given
and so as a result the and then also
oftentimes the Tas are different the
instructors are different and so forth
and so
um you don't have kind of a static data
set or a static problem you actually
have lots of different assignments exams
rubrics student Solutions and so forth
cool so does anyone have any ideas for
how you could frame this as a meta
learning problem
I guess to start off the kind of the
Mediterranean data set that we have
available to us is four final exams and
four midterms from cs106a this has a
number of different questions and each
student solution has feedback from a
rubric
yeah I guess you can look at a question
by question and then for each question
I guess with each type of like being
tasked with the rubric can be like a
tasked for the model yeah exactly so you
could go question by question and
um essentially each item on the rubric
can correspond to a different task where
you can formulate each for each rubric
for each question will basically be a
different task and your goal is to very
quickly
um be able to give feedback on that
rubric item with a small amount of
labeled data
um and so each rubric has several items
um and
every question has possibly its own set
of rubric items and options and so for
that reason you can basically have each
rubric item as a different task
so if if you had a string insertion
problem and your rubric looks something
like this where maybe
um one option is for the solution to be
perfect another option is for the um for
the student to kind of incorrectly
um incorrectly insert the wrong
character and so on and so forth then
each item here can be just a different
task for running meta training
and then once you have all these tasks
um you can apply the Better Learning
algorithms that we've looked at in the
class
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to apply prototypical networks
which is what we talked about on the
last slide there's also a typo in this
equation again
and X corresponds to a sequence of
discrete tokens so it's going to be in
this case python code
or pseudo python code depending on how
good the student was
and the embedding function because it's
going to be text we're going to use a
Burt based model called the Roberta
model that's going to take as input the
python code and output and embedding of
that Python program
um and then unfortunately uh when we use
prototypical networks out of the box
with the Roberta model uh it doesn't do
very well and so attention isn't quite
all you need
and there are some tricks that we needed
to get it to work a lot better
um the first was that instead of only
using the tasks from the rubrics in our
data set we can augment those tasks with
other tasks that can be constructed in a
self-supervised manner
so
um we can construct a task for example
by predicting the compilation error that
python returns if you try to run the
program
we can also
construct tasks similar to mask language
modeling where you are trying to predict
the token that has been masked out and
that can also be formulated as a
classification problem where you want to
classify whether or not that token is a
four token or an in token and so forth
so that's going to augment our data set
significantly
another thing that we can do is instead
of only giving it a few examples we can
also incorporate side information so we
have information about the name of the
rubric option as well as the text of the
question
and we can basically pass this into the
embedding function uh to inform the
network what the task might be
and so when we encode the program here
we're also going to prepend the site
information which will also be encoded
with a bird-like model
um great and then the last trick is um
instead of only using data from the
exams and assignments that I mentioned
before we can also use a pre-trained
model so instead of randomly
initializing the Roberto model we'll
pre-train it on um with a model called
code bird that was pre-trained on a ton
of unlabeled python code uh from the
internet
cool
um so the gist of the method is still
prototypical networks it just is that
there's kind of three small changes to
it one is that we are using these
additional tasks the second is that we
are incorporating the site information
into the embedding and the third is that
we're going to pre-train the weights of
the encoder
um as a whole the model looks like this
where we have our site information
that's encoded and pre-pended into the
Transformer layers we embed the student
code into embeddings and we'll then
average those embeddings to form a
prototype for each
um for each label for each rubric option
and then we'll train the whole network
end to end initialized with the code
Bird model
cool
um so how well does this work
um our first results were actually just
offline on held out exams and how that
rubrics from Stanford data
um we found that first it outperforms
supervised learning by 8 to 17 which is
fairly significant
um eight percent in the held out exam
case and 17 in the held out rubric case
um in the case where you have it held at
rubric is actually more accurate than a
human ta
um it turns out human Tas are actually
not that good at at grading uh it's
actually really like grading code
actually just involves debugging the
code itself and so
um yeah it's actually pretty hard
but there's also a lot still a lot of
room to grow in terms of the held out
exam Health exams are harder than held
at rubrics because they might involve
tokens that were unseen during training
um
because of kind of the questions and and
things being entirely new
um
the more exciting thing was actually
trying to actually deploy this a code in
place uh in particular
um
this a lot of this was in collaboration
with Chris Peach and Chris Peach
promised the code and place people that
we would uh give them feedback on their
um on their diagnostic on May 10th the
students took the diagnostic and I think
we had about one week to give feedback
on all the assignments or on all the
solutions
um Alan and Chris made a cool UI that
looks like this where
um we paired the predicted rubric option
with text that describes the feedback
for that rubric option and that was
presented to the student in this purple
box here
the students then evaluated the feedback
whether or not they agreed with feedback
or disagreed with the feedback
um and we also tried to use attention to
highlight where where the algorithm
thought the error might be arising from
um and it's lastly worth mentioning that
things like syntax errors can prevent
unit tests from being useful and giving
feedback and so
um there are some some data
some solutions we were able to give
feedback automatically to
um but a lot the bulk of the solutions
we're not able to give automatic
feedback on
specifically for the highlighting yeah
yeah so the highlighting it worked
um
I think it worked a pretty good amount
of the time but it didn't work 100 of
the time
um the way that we did that I don't know
if I would necessarily recommend this
but the way that we did it is we kind of
randomly
um masked out part of the input and then
tried to see if the prediction of the
model changed and if it did change and
that's kind of an indication that the
error may have occurred in that part of
the program but it wasn't the most
reliable and in general interpretability
is a very kind of open area of research
in deep learning
yeah was there an abortion study to see
which one of the tricks helps the most
yeah um so there's a pretty detailed
ablation study I don't have the slides
here but you can take a look at the
paper to see it
um the gist is that actually all of them
helped a lot uh and the three that I
covered um I think that they're helping
buy upwards of 10
um accuracy
yeah
yeah so the question is can this model
also understand if students like kind of
edge cases and so forth so
is only going to understand the kind of
the rubric options you give it uh and so
if there's something that's not on the
rubric it's not going to understand that
um
and it also still needs a few examples
of a test time
um for the rubric
um cool but so let's get into some of
the results from actually the live
deployment so we actually gave this to
the students uh in the code in place
course
um we got humans to actually volunteer
to give a thousand uh feedback or
feedback on a thousand different student
Solutions and then we had the system
give feedback on the remaining 15 000
Solutions
um and then around 2000 of the solutions
could be Auto graded and then they
weren't included in any of the analysis
um
and then in terms of giving the feedback
um for the student for the 15 000 that
were graded by the system
um that's the feedback that the students
got for the a thousand they got the
human feedback the students didn't know
if they were getting human feedback or
ai-based feedback although they did know
that we were running a study as part of
the process
uh first we looked at how much the
students agreed with the feedback from
the kind of prototypical network space
system versus the human feedback and uh
we actually somewhat surprised to see
that they actually agreed with the
feedback from the system slightly more
um so and also in general they agreed
with the feedback a lot uh so in general
it was like I think it was like 97
versus like 98 or maybe 96 versus 97 so
uh it seems to work actually quite well
um now they might agree with the
feedback but not actually find it useful
for example if you always said good job
they might kind of agree with that but
not find it very useful and so we asked
them how useful they found the feedback
out of this kind of a rating from one to
five and they gave it a kind of a 4.6
out of 5 in terms of usefulness which
suggests that they actually find it
useful in pointing out their
misconceptions
do something
it was like they were able and for the
1000 scoring support like I'm lucky to
get the switch to like if the people
properly so you're asking what about
students who didn't give feedback on the
feedback
because
yeah
first the students didn't know if it was
human feedback or not and so this
comparison should very much hold water
because they're not gonna just they're
not gonna like abstain at different
rates
um the other thing that we did is in the
interface we gave the feedback one by
one and to go to the next one to
actually see the feedback for the next
question they had to give feedback on
the first question
uh and so we yeah we require that they
kind of stated whether or not they
agreed with it or not
um it's possible that not all students
actually looked at the feedback
um I don't know exactly what the rate of
that was
yeah did experts also create this apart
from the students by any chance um the
humans here were actually kind of
um basically volunteer Tas for the
course
feedback uh did any experts also review
the feedback and uh said whether the
feedback would be useful yeah we did not
have
um experts look at the feedback so these
were the only evaluations that we read
feedback
um that's a good question I I don't know
off the top of my head but I think the
answer was no and I should mention that
the in some ways this is like kind of a
hybrid human AI system in some ways
because
um this text was written by Chris
actually uh and so it was it was doing
the bulk of the work which was to figure
out which rubric item it was
um and then for each of those rubric
items Chris wrote that text and the text
from Chris was was put in the Box
um this still saved like
almost all of the work needed to give
feedback because Chris just needed to
enter that text for each of the items in
the rubric once
um but I think that because of because
it's very similar I wouldn't expect
there to be a significant difference in
usefulness
cool and then the last thing that we
checked just as a Sandy check we weren't
really expecting to see any bias but we
wanted to check that
um that the model wasn't picking up on
something that we wouldn't be aware of
and so we looked at the agreement by
different
um the two most common gender
um
demographics and the two most common or
the three most common countries in the
data set and saw that there weren't any
signs of um of bias uh this was expected
because we removed all the comments from
the code and uh really there probably
isn't that much information in the code
that reveals this sort of thing but it's
always good to do these sorts of checks
in um in these kinds of studies as well
cool
um yeah so that was a case study of
actually using prototypical networks in
a real application we're also trying to
kind of continue to improve on it we
actually have a little bit more data now
and so we're hoping to
improve that bar a little bit more
[Music]
um
now I'd like to talk a little bit about
how the different approaches compare so
we've talked about Black Box battling we
talked about optimization based meta
learning and today we talked about these
more non-parametric approaches and I
think it's useful to take a high level
view to understand like when should you
use one algorithm versus the other and
how do they compare to each other
um first we can compare them at a
conceptual level so
um we mentioned we walked through this
kind of computation graph perspective on
meta learning in Monday's lecture and we
saw that both Black Box meta learning
and optimization based meta learning are
both a computation graph that takes this
input the training data set and the test
example and makes a prediction for that
test example
um non-parametric approaches can be
viewed in the same exact way so you can
also view something like prototypical
networks as having the same form of
computation graph
um it's just what happens on the inside
in the Inner Loop that differs between
it
um and so in particular
the um the
yeah it makes its predictions for test
inputs using something like nearest
neighbors or nearest neighbors to
prototypes
um where the equation for the Prototype
is kind of the average embedding so as a
whole you can sort of view all of these
approaches as being kind of the same
family of metal learning algorithms and
they're all optimized end to end with
respect to some meta learning objective
the difference is just whether or not
you don't give it any structure at all
and you represent it as a neural network
versus embedding gradient descent versus
embedding something like nearest
neighbors and this also suggests that
it's possible that there may be a fourth
class of approaches approach that comes
up that embeds something that looks a
little bit different from these other
methods
um and like we mentioned before you can
also again kind of mix and match
different aspects of this computation
graph and get algorithms that aren't
clearly in kind of one of these three
buckets
um so for example there are algorithms
that both kind of condition the network
on the data and run gradient descent
so that would be a hybrid between a
black box approach and an optimization
based approach
there are also an algorithm that does
something like relation networks which
we had talked about here where you kind
of learn this distance function
um
and actually run gradient descent on
that relation Network embedding and so
that would be a hybrid between
optimization based and non-parametric
based
um and then there's also approaches that
do something like mammal but initialize
uh the last layer as um as a
prototypical network
um so
I guess in general I think it's useful
and pedagogical to think about these
three different categories but there
really is a spectrum in between these
and there's lots of algorithms that
don't fall into one of these three
categories super cleanly
um
then beyond kind of the beyond the
conceptual uh similarities between these
algorithms we can also think about the
properties that they have
um one property that we've talked about
a little bit is expressive power
and by that I mean the ability for the
learner to represent a wide range of
learning procedures
and we want to have expressive power
because it means that we might be able
to scale to scenarios where we have lots
of meta training data and we want to
learn a really good learning algorithm
um and it also means that it might be
applicable to a wider range of domains
where maybe we don't have good learning
algorithms
um Beyond expressive power
there's a second property that I think
is useful which I'll refer to as
consistency
which is that
um
regardless of what you do in the meta
training process it would be nice if
your learning procedure monotonically
improved as you gave it more training
data
um and this is useful because you might
be you might get a test task that's
pretty different from your Mediterranean
tasks and if you do get an auto
distribution task it'd be nice if your
algorithm still does something somewhat
reasonable on those tasks and so this
sort of property will reduce the
Reliance on having a large number of
meta training tasks
and it should give you in principle
somewhat better
Ood task performance
um and you can kind of remember the the
kind of the performance that we looked
at when we kind of increased we made the
task more and more out of distribution
and we saw that an algorithm like mammal
which is which is actually consistent uh
does better than algorithms that are not
consistent
yeah is consistency the same concept has
generalizability
um the question is consistency the same
concept as generalizability
um I think that consistency implies that
it will that the algorithm should
generalize better
um but not vice versa you could have
something that does seem to generalize
well but isn't guaranteed to improve
with more data and expectation
um yeah they're certainly related
cool um so I think these properties are
pretty important for a lot of
applications
um we and we can think of each of these
algorithms within the context of those
properties and black box methods have
complete expressive power but are not
consistent if you give them more data
they won't necessarily get better
optimization based methods are
consistent and that they've reduced to
gradient descent and they're expressive
if you give them a very deep model
um
for supervised learning settings
um and then non-parametric methods are
expressive for most architectures
um that you that you give it and under
certain conditions they can also be
consistent
um essentially you can expect them to be
consistent if the if your betting
function doesn't compress too much about
the input
if it compresses uh if it compresses too
much then it may no longer be consistent
because you may have two examples that
are very similar to each other but your
embedding space doesn't actually put
them as similar to each other because it
kind of compressed away some of the
details
um and then beyond these properties um I
think there's always like there's
there's other pros and cons of these
algorithms as well
um we talked a little bit about the pros
and cons of black box and optimization
based methods in the previous lectures
and these were that black box is easy to
combine with a variety of learning
problems but can be challenging to
optimize and as a result be data
inefficient
optimization based Better Learning
algorithms have a positive inductive
bias at the start of meta learning and
they also are pretty good at handling
varying
amounts of K and large numbers of
examples well because you're averaging
across those examples when you compute
the gradient
but they involve a second order
optimization that can be compute and
memory intensive
now for non-parametric approaches
um
they're kind of an entirely feed forward
process you never have this sort of
gradient descent step and so as a result
they end up being computationally very
fast and usually pretty easy to optimize
uh
in practice people have found that if
you have varying K it's somewhat harder
to generalize to varying k i don't
honestly have great intuition for why
this is the case but it's a kind of an
empirical observation that people have
made in the past
um and also that it can be difficult to
scale to a very large k
um the reason why it's difficult to
scale to very large K is because you
have to make
um you have to make comparisons to all
the examples in your training set and in
general nearest neighbors and
non-parametric methods don't scale to
very large data sets because you have to
um
because the kind of the runtime of your
algorithm is uh is open
or or over n times K in this case
um and then the last thing which was
mentioned before is that these methods
are entirely limited to classification
um yeah
cool so
um and then I guess the other thing that
I'll mention here is that
on many few shot learning benchmarks if
you tune these algorithms well
oftentimes you'll see that all three of
these can perform quite well on those
Benchmark problems
I think this says a little bit more
about the benchmarks than than the
methods I think the benchmarks may just
be a little bit too easy
um and I think that which method you use
will depend on your use case
so in general
um my recommendation is if you have a
supervised classification problem I
think that non-parametric methods are
um are would generally be my
recommendation because they're very fast
and easy to optimize
um and they tend to work well for
classification uh but if you don't have
a classification problem then you need
to use one of the other two approaches
um and usually in that case I might
recommend an optimization based metal
learning approach
um and uh there are a few instances
where I might recommend a block box
approach um Black Box approaches I think
are actually quite useful in scenarios
um in reinforcement learning scenarios
uh
in part because we don't actually have
good interloop optimization methods for
reinforcement learning
um and then lastly if you have a ton a
ton and ton of data things like black
box approaches can can make sense
because they're so expressive and
because you don't care as much about
data efficiency and that's why we've
seen things like gpt3 uh I think be very
effective with a black box model
yeah
what exactly here made my entirely fleet
farmer we are we are doing a training
right so by entirely feed forward I mean
that at meta test time it's entirely
feet forward so like the inner loop
process is a feed forward
computation graph
um
and actually the same could be true for
a block Box model as well although Black
Box models often may have some amount of
recurrence
um but yeah so I mean in contrast to
optimization based methods where you're
running gradient descendant test time
these approaches are just a forward pass
through
um through things through a neural
network
um algorithms we still need to upgrade a
bunch of like a very large number of
tasks and
if we if we have like a small number of
passes or generating a new task is still
uh expensive so like we only have like
dozens of tasks instead of hundreds of
thousands we used to recommend using
multitask
or otherwise
yeah so the question is um all these
methods require a fairly large number of
tasks and if you have a small number of
tasks would I recommend using multitask
learning instead of meta learning
yeah so um first off I would say that in
general
um in settings where you have a small
number of tasks uh things that that's
where consistency can be very important
because if it is still running something
like gradient descent on that new task
then uh
it is less reliant on having a large
number of meta training tasks
um
the
and then there's I think two others two
other things that you can do when you
have a small number of tasks
um the first is that you can do task
augmentation which we saw in the
education example on in some scenarios
it's it's possible to come up with those
kinds of tasks and other scenarios that
might be more difficult and then whether
or not to use multitask learning or meta
learning I think is um
it depends a lot on the particulars of
the problem uh the in general if there's
a small number of tasks I do think that
multitask learning can be a can be a
better approach especially if
um
especially if you don't mind training on
all the tasks at once
um whereas in meta learning one thing
that's nice about these metal learning
algorithms is you can train on all your
meta training tasks first
then kind of encapsulate that into a
model throw away kind of your meditating
task data and then apply that to the
meta test task so I think that generally
the um whether to use kind of meta
learning or whether you use multitask
learning will depend
uh depend a bit on the considerations
like that
yeah so the question was um four
classification tasks is there a reason
to prefer non-parametric methods over
optimization based methods and generally
my recommendation is just because of
compute these will require uh generally
will typically require less compute
during The Meta training process they'll
also be a little bit lighter weight and
so in the education example when we had
um
when we're processing python code with
these based models trying to do a
bi-level optimization with a Bert model
um gets computationally expensive fairly
quickly and if you have a feed forward
process it's uh these computational
benefits are quite nice
um but again it does by kind of default
or rough recommendation and there may be
applications where an optimization based
method May
um may be preferable especially for
example if you have like a larger k or a
variant k or something like that
yeah
that there were intermediates whether it
was a spectrum between these what would
be a combination between a
non-parametric method
yeah so
um I mentioned one combination on the
on the previous slide and in particular
what it was doing is it was um
it oh I didn't mention on this slide
which slide was it
so
uh these second two methods are kind of
examples of hybrids of non-parametric
and optimization based methods
um for example the second one it
actually kind of learns this embedding
space and then does gradient descent on
that embedding space and so that's a
little bit of a hybrid I also think that
matching networks itself is somewhat of
a hybrid between non-parametric methods
and block box methods because it uses
this kind of bi-directional lstm to
encode the examples in the training set
cool
um
great and then in the last eight minutes
um or actually before we do that first
um there's also a third property which
we'll talk about in a couple weeks which
is
um uncertainty awareness
uh in general if you're in a few shot
learning regime there may be some
ambiguity with respect to what the task
is and it'd be nice if the network would
tell you
given the few examples that I have I
need more data in order to figure out a
good classifier for this task
um and this can be useful in active
learning settings and settings where you
need calibrated uncertainty estimates
like in safety critical settings also in
reinforcement learning
um or if you care about uh kind of
driving things from first principles
from a Bayesian standpoint
Um this can also be useful and we'll
talk about uh kind of uncertainty where
meta learning algorithms in
actually it might be three weeks it's
either two weeks or three weeks in the
in the basement learning lecture
cool
I was briefly run through a few
applications
um just to give you uh even more of an
idea of the kinds of problems that these
methods can be applied to
um
and also um in some ways some of these
are actually somewhat creative and
actually how they how they use metal
learning algorithms so in the first
lecture I showed you this video of um
doing One-Shot imitation learning and
the different tasks correspond to
manipulating different objects and the
uh kind of training example corresponded
to a video of a human and the test
example corresponded to a teleoperated
demonstration of
um of that task
the model here was an optimization based
meta learning algorithm so it was
something like mammal
and one thing that was cool about this
is that uh when you have a video of a
human you don't actually have labels
uh you just have input images you don't
know what actions the robot should take
and so this approach actually used a
learned inner loss function
uh and so instead of only learning the
initialization of the model it also
learned a loss function that was used to
run gradient descent in the Inner Loop
and so this is an example of something
where uh instead of yeah instead of only
like meta learning one component of the
system you can better learn other
components of the system as well
um and so kind of
um the way that this ended up working is
that at test time you give it
um a video but you've been doing the
task it runs gradient descent on this
video with the Learned inner loss
function uh to get a policy for the task
and then the results of running that
policy on the robot is something like
this where it can successfully figure
out that it should be going to the Red
Bull
um a second example uh is looking at
predicting the properties of molecules
this is potentially useful in drug
Discovery problems where you only have a
small amount of experimental data for a
given molecule
um the
uh the task is to predict the properties
and activities of different molecules
um for example you might have some
experiments that are cheaper or easier
to run and you want to predict uh kind
of activities that are more expensive to
run
and here they used optimization based
methods they actually looked at mammal
first order mammal and a variant of
mammal that only updates the last layer
of the model in the Inner Loop
and they were using a kind of a graph
neural network as the base model
um and they found that these metal
learning algorithms were able to do
better than uh fine-tuning or k nearest
Neighbors
uh and then the last application that
I'll mention here is a fuchsia and
motion prediction
um this could potentially be useful for
human robot interaction where you want
to predict the motion of people or an
autonomous driving where you want to
predict the motion of other cars
and the task correspond to different
users and different underlying motions
basically different trajectories and the
training data set correspond to the path
K time steps emotion and the test set
corresponded to the Future seconds of
motion
um they use kind of a hybrid of an
optimization in a black box approach
here
um so they had this kind of learned
update rule in the Inner Loop
and they were able to uh yeah in this
case predict kind of the motion of these
human skeletons uh fairly accurately and
were able to do so much more effectively
than a multitask learning approach or or
a transfer learning approach
cool um so those were just three
applications that I think are kind of
uh survey the spectrum of kind of
problems that you might look at in Med
learning examples
there's less lastly kind of one closing
note that I'd like to mention which kind
of gets at one of the things that we saw
in the first application
um which is that kind of so far whenever
we sample a kind of a train set and a
test set we've been looking at examples
where we kind of sample them IID from
the same distribution
and they don't actually need to be
sampled independently from one another
uh the training data the kind of the
inner loop training data that you're
learning from it could have noisy labels
it could be weekly supervised
um and not actually have exactly the
label that you want
um it could have domain shift that's
different from uh what you see in the
outer loop test examples
and
this is kind of cool because it means
that you can actually kind of
metal learn for learning procedures that
are more robust to noisy labels that can
learn from weak supervision that can
learn from other forms of supervision
than typical forms of machine learning
um and so yeah in general the inner loop
and outer loop don't have to be the same
um
on this note it is really important for
the test set to be a well-formed machine
learning objective because that's going
to drive the meta learning process and
optimize for that learning procedure
um but it's really the inner loop that
can be uh almost anything that you want
in some sense although you do need to
have enough supervision and enough
information in the Inner Loop for the
model to be able to infer what it's
supposed to be doing
yeah
this is true for black box too so when
you pass in your
um your examples your X train and Y
train you could have noisy example like
noisy labels that are being passed in or
you could have supervision that's a
little bit different than kind of a one
hot Vector for example question is does
domain shift mean the scaling and the
shifting that was done for the normal
yeah so for domain shift um kind of what
I had in mind there is um say you want
to learn a classifier uh between like
maybe you want to learn an image
classifier and you want to be able to
train an image classifier with like
sketches of things
um so that if you give it like a sketch
of a cat and a sketch of a dog it learns
a good cat vs dog classifier then D
train could be sketches and detest could
be natural images and black box methods
could work well for that or or
optimization based methods or um or
possibly things like prototypical
networks
um
I guess in that example I would guess
that
in general Black Box methods could
actually be a better choice in some of
those scenarios because it is very
expressive in the learning procedures it
can learn
um
and like for things like
but yeah in general like expect kind of
uh
all the algorithms that we've covered to
be able to handle these kinds of things
cool
um so that's it for today uh we talked
about non-parametric view shot learning
algorithms we compared the different
approaches this is the last lecture on
meta learning algorithms and next week
we'll talk about unsupervised
pre-training methods and also a little
bit into how these relate to meta
learning algorithms and how you can view
some of them in a similar light and then
there's also some reminders about
coursework on the right